[Music]
and action
do you guys mind giving like a summary
of the movie
so joe gardner was a band teacher
and then he was invited to be a
full-time band teacher
with health insurance and stuff like
that i don't know a lot about adulthood
then he got a job with dorothea williams
he falls into a hole he's in the great
beyond he's 22
then when he finally opens the portal he
accidentally knocks in 22 with him and
now he's in the cat
and 22's on the body while they are
there they have a great adventure
22 loves pizza she's like it's so good
are there characters um fixed that
remind you of your sister
i'm 22 because my sister likes
to mess around with my papa
do you have a favorite scene in the
whole movie
i think it's time to do the h-e-l-l
you ready one two three hell
hell hell hell hell hell quiet coyote
that was awesome well done do you know
what an oscar is
no fix do you know what an oscar is no
it's a statue that you get if your movie
is good i think seoul should already
have an oscar i'd send an oscar
for the most emotional movie what if he
had to give an oscar to fix
what would he win for like best adorable
brother
oh yeah dana is actually
the producer of seoul do you know that
this is pete doctor the director of
seoul
nobody told us and now i'm gonna freak
out
do you have any questions for us does
joe gardner
meet 22 now that she has her personal
own life
it's a good question you know what when
we were writing the movie
we found out if there's close to eight
billion people
on the planet what do you think are the
chances that joe will run into 22.
but what if joe gardner becomes famous
at some point
he might just travel all over the world
and meet 22 while doing so
it was really nice meeting you guys
thanks for thanks for joining us it was
nice
meeting the producers and the directors
for seoul thank you
you